[APPLAUSE]
ALAN: Hey, hello everyone.
Thank you for coming out, taking
this hour out of your day.
I'm going to let the
show speak for itself.
The show's creator, I'm going
to introduce Dennis here.
Don't forget though,
before they come up,
visit go/disenchanted-discount
for a Googler exclusive
discount that gets you some
extremely discounted very
inexpensive tickets for
this amazing hilarious show.
So make sure to check that out.
So without further
ado, here to introduced
the cast of the hilarious
musical "DISENCHANTED!", now
in performances at
the Westside theater
Upstairs on West
43rd Street, please
welcome "DISENCHANTED!"'s author
and composer, Dennis Giacino.
[APPLAUSE]
DENNIS GIACINO: Hey everybody.
Thank you.
Thanks so much for spending some
time this afternoon with us.
That's the director of
the show, Fiely Matias.
He helped me co-create the
show with a GoPro of course.
And so I'm going
to introduce you
to some of the ladies who are
going to sing with us today.
But let me tell you about
the show real quick.
So the show "DISENCHANTED!" is
about the original fairytale
princesses from the
old story books who've
really kind of have it up
to their crowns with the way
that they're portrayed
in today's pop culture
as helpless damsels in distress,
specifically the Disney films.
So they've come to life.
They've come out
of the story books
and onto the off Broadway stage
to tell the truth about happily
ever after.
They bippity boppity bust
out a little princess show
of their own.
So before we get
into the show, let
me introduce some
other folks who are
going to sing for you today.
Let's see.
First off, we have our
Princess who kissed the frog.
That's Karen Burthwright.
[CHEERING]
Right after her is our
Little Mermaid, Alison Burns.
[CHEERING]
And then of course we
have Erin Leigh Peck,
who we're going to talk about.
She plays a whole slew of
princesses in the show.
And of course, our Mulan,
and that's Lulu Picart.
Great.
Over at the piano is
Michael Raby on the keys.
We're here all week.
Try the Veal.
OK, so the show itself.
You know what it's about.
Let's talk about how
we came up with it.
So I used to be
history teacher and I
used to teach about
Pocahontas all the time
in American history to little
seventh and eighth graders.
Thank god I'm
doing that anymore.
No, it was fun.
[LAUGHTER]
It was great.
Never grow older,
you're so cute now.
So I taught history and
taught about Pocahontas.
The real Pocahontas in
history, about the time
she supposedly met John
Smith, she was 10 years old
and she was little tomboy.
And then of course,
out came the movie,
the Disney movie in 1995.
And there was Pocahontas
and she was all
growed up in all growed out.
And she was about
20-something years old.
And she was leaping
and doing swan dives
off waterfalls and leaves
were following her everywhere.
And I thought, I wonder
what the 10-year-old tomboy,
the real Pocahontas thinks
about this Pocahontas up
on the screen.
And so I wrote a song,
and I started to wonder.
And Erin's like that's the
name of my song "I Wonder."
I'm up now.
And so I started to wonder
what would the other princesses
from the Disney movies,
from the original tales
think about their counterparts
in the Disney movies.
Look what the directory
does, he moves a mic stand.
And--
ERIN LEIGH PECK:
That's really stealthy,
you can't even see him.
DENNIS GIACINO: $3,000 a week.
ERIN LEIGH PECK: How
did that get there?
[LAUGHTER]
DENNIS GIACINO: So I
started to wonder what
do the other processes think.
And here's Erin Leigh Peck.
One thing you should
know about Erin Leigh
is Erin Leigh Peck
plays, let's see,
Snow White, Cinderella,
Sleeping Beauty,
the Little Mermaid,
Rapunzel and Belle.
ERIN LEIGH PECK: Bing.
DENNIS GIACINO: She's
understudies all of those.
She's learned every one of
those roles in the show.
She's a superwoman.
And she's going to sing a song.
ERIN LEIGH PECK: Congratulations
for doing your job, Erin.
DENNIS GIACINO: That's right.
She's going to sing a
song called "I Wonder"
which sort of sums up how
I came up with the show.
Here she is, Erin Leigh
Peck and "I Wonder."
[MUSIC ERIN LEIGH PECK, "I
WONDER"]
ERIN LEIGH PECK: Wonder no
more because "DISENCHANTED!"
is here to tell you the truth.
[APPLAUSE]
DENNIS GIACINO: Erin
Leigh Peck, terrific.
Great.
Now of course, one such princess
I wondered about, of course,
was the Little Mermaid.
Now her story, all the way
back in Hans Christian Andersen
books, she starts out as this
little teenage girl who's
swims around under the ocean.
And she decides
to give up one day
her father, her fin, even her
voice, all her friends just
to net a man.
And that man happens to
be in love with somebody
else who he falls
in love with her
and then she decides
oh well, I've
got to get rid of that girl.
So she decides I want
to kill that girl.
And she goes to try
and kill that girl,
but then decides she's
going to kill self instead,
throws her overboard sorry.
And throws herself overboard
and drowns in the ocean,
becomes sea foam
forever and hovers over
hims like a stalker.
Yeah, so it's not
a Lifetime movie.
It's actually a Hans
Christian Andersen story.
So I decided that
was a bit much.
And Disney kind of kept
true to most of that
about this girl who
gave up everything
she had just to get a guy.
Now, we've all been
in relationships
and we kind of do that right?
And we give up a little
bit of ourselves.
So I decided I wanted to write
this song about the Little
Mermaid who gave up her
father, her fin, and her voice
just to get a dude
and then started
to regret the choices
that she made.
It's in a song called "Two
Legs." and here's Alison Burns.
Yes, I decided also
that I was going
to take the mermaid in
a different direction.
So I was going to make
her sort of trailer
trashy and from the South.
ALISON BURNS: I was typecast.
[LAUGHTER]
DENNIS GIACINO:
She's from Tampa.
[LAUGHTER]
So here is Alison
Burns, a little tipsy,
singing the Little Mermaid
song called "Two Legs."
ALISON BURNS: Yeah.
All right, so you
can keep vamping.
Thank you.
I've been quiet a long time.
Right?
[GASPING]
Took my voice.
But now I've got a lot
to say, got a lot to say.
[MUSIC ALISON BURNS, "TWO LEGS"]
[APPLAUSE]
DENNIS GIACINO: Alison Burns.
ALISON BURNS: Yeah!
[LAUGHTER]
DENNIS GIACINO: Our
tipsy Little Mermaid.
Well as you can tell, this isn't
quite the Disney movies right.
Very good.
By the way Allison plays
three roles in the show.
She plays the Little Mermaid.
She also plays Belle from
"Beauty and the Beast"
who sings a song called
insane, because she
talks to inanimate objects and I
don't know a little bestiality.
[LAUGHTER]
It's all from Tampa.
And then of course,
also plays Rapunzel
which is our German
princess in the show.
So Alison Burns, we love her.
OK, so there are a
whole slew of princesses
who have a bone to
pick on our show over
at the Westside Theater.
They have a bone to pick
with our old buddy Walt.
All of them are ready to go
all Norma Rae on his ass.
So one such princess is the
princess who kissed the frog.
Disney finally came
out with a movie
after making movies about
cars and bugs and toys.
They decided hey, you
know now it's time
to make a movie about an
African American princess.
And so it was called, I think,
"The Princess and the Frog."
Is that right?
We call ours the princess
who kissed the frog,
because in the Disney
movie this black princess
spent most of the movie
green because she was a frog.
So hey, wait, great, terrific.
So we decided that's not
really the right way to do it.
So we decided we
were going to make
our African American princes
powerful, very empowered,
and a lot of fun.
So Karen Burthwright is
going to sing in this song.
It's a song called "Finally."
She'll be introduced
by Erin Leigh Peck.
Here we go.
[MUSIC ERIN LEIGH PECK, KAREN
BURTHWRIGHT, "FINALLY"]
[APPLAUSE]
DENNIS GIACINO:
Karen Burthwright.
So those are just a few of the
songs actually from the show.
It's a fun show.
It's 90 minutes,
no intermission.
We're over at the
Westside Theater.
Thanks to Erin Leigh
Peck today, Lulu Picart,
Alison Burns Ken
Burnthwright, Michael Raby.
And where's Alan?
I think we have a Q&A that
comes up where you can
ask us anything about the show.
[APPLAUSE]
Here he is.
This isn't over.
ALAN: Yes, so the show gosh,
why you wrote "DISENCHANTED!".
It all came from
ex-history teacher.
Why were you
originally persuaded
to go from teacher to
play writer, songwriter?
DENNIS GIACINO: It's really
kind of a weird story.
I was teaching one day and
I was very good friends
with the person in
the room next to me.
And her husband came to school
one day just to pick her up
and say hello and stuff.
And he heard me teaching
and he said hey,
I think I could be
a voice over artist.
This is how it happens right?
And so there I was teaching
probably about Pocahontas,
and I got discovered.
I don't know.
Before I knew it, I was in a
booth recording commercials
for Bank of America,
sorry, and life insurance.
I was always the voice
of that guy, hey,
I just got back from Hawaii.
It was a great time.
So I was the cheesy voice.
And so I went into
voice overs which
brought me into New York City.
And that's how I fell
in love with theater
and started to write.
It was embarrassingly good
money, but soul sucking.
So that's when I
moved onto writing.
So, you do voice
overs don't you?
Everybody does a few.
ERIN LEIGH PECK: Yeah.
DENNIS GIACINO:
Yeah, so that's--
ALAN: I don't.
DENNIS GIACINO:
You don't do voice.
Really good money.
ERIN LEIGH PECK: Nice
work if you can get it.
DENNIS GIACINO: Nice
Ten minutes and lots of money.
ALAN: So the show, started out
in the New Jersey Playwrights
Contest in '09.
Sold out performances in 2011
in the Orlando Fringe Festival
and then yeah, woo.
And then had a limited run off
Broadway last year, correct?
And so now you're back,
open ended run right?
So that's wonderful.
Lulu you've been in it
since the beginning.
LULU PICART: True.
[LAUGHTER]
DENNIS GIACINO:
Three plus years.
ALAN: And so how, has the show--
[LAUGHTER]
More than three, but good.
So how has the show
changed for you?
Or how have you seen the show
change over the five plus
years?
LULU PICART: It changes
from night to night.
However, I have
been really lucky
because normally as actors
we don't get the chance
to go from a to z with a show.
You usually stay in for
a little phase of it
and you're lucky
enough to have that.
And then you may come in and
out of a show wherever it is.
But because I've been
in with the beginning
with Dennis and Fiely,
we've changed cast sizes.
Songs of gone away,
songs have come back.
We didn't have costumes.
Now, we have costumes.
We used to have Dennis at the
piano by himself in the back.
And now we have a band
and music on paper.
I mean you know it's like
we're in the big time now.
So Yeah, not to lie, we started
out making $40 a weekend
with the show, $25 a show.
It was awesome.
My parents are very proud.
I'm still paying off college.
And now it's really wonderful
to come to New York.
We're in an open ended run,
which means that basically
they'll run it until they can't.
We don't have an end date to
it, which is a lovely thing.
It means there's a lot of
faith with the producers
and with the public
and the ticket sales.
So to go from a to z is
a luxury for an actor
that doesn't always happen.
DENNIS GIACINO: And can we say
that she has gone all the way
from the Orlando Fringe to being
nominated for a Lucille Lortel
Award this year--
[APPLAUSE]
--for this very role.
Congrats.
LULU PICART: Thank you.
ALAN: So when Michael, the
music director, Fiely, director
director, actor director.
You direct the music,
he directs the actors.
When and how did you
guys come on board?
FIELY MATIAS: I've been on
board since, we've been working
together for over 20 years.
So we've created shows
and this was a show
that we created
about five years ago.
So that's it.
[LAUGHTER]
DENNIS GIACINO: Wow.
ALAN: All right, all right.
MICHAEL RABY: And I came on
board for the last out of town
tryout in Tampa.
They did a production before
coming to New York here.
And it was great meeting
Dennis and Fiely right away.
I'd worked with Lulu
before in some shows
and actually Alison as well.
But I loved the show.
I'd seen the show
before I came on board
and fell in love with it and
they asked me to come on board
and come to New York.
And it's been thrilling.
It's such a wonderful
score and it's
a lot of fun to do everything.
ALAN: So OK, name all
the princesses for me.
There's Snow White and
Cinderella and Sleeping Beauty.
I'm trying to remember
which names I could say
and which ones I can't
for copyright reasons.
DENNIS GIACINO: You
can't say Ariel or Tiana.
ERIN LEIGH PECK: You just did.
ALAN: But you just did.
DENNIS GIACINO: But you can't.
ERIN LEIGH PECK:
TM, TM, TM, TM, TM.
ALAN: We'll have to bleep those
out in the recording I guess.
OK so there's
those three who are
like the emcees of the show.
Why is Snow White
like the ring leader?
DENNIS GIACINO: Oh well, she
was the first Disney princess.
So all the way back in the
1930s, 1934, 2 something
like that.
And so I thought that
has to be my ring
leader when I write the show.
She was the first.
Cinderella was the
second, so she's
always playing catch
up to Snow White
and thinks she could do Snow
White's job, but can't quite.
She's a little ditsy.
And then the third of
course was Sleeping Beauty.
And that's sort of
the pecking order
as we go in through the show.
Those are our main
three characters.
Then we introduce this host
of both crazies in the show.
LULU PICART: Typcast.
DENNIS GIACINO: And
each one of them
one at a time with
Snow White at the lead,
they sort of take on
the princess complex,
this age old idea
where unless you're
pretty in a Bambi-like waif and
a helpless damsel in distress,
you're not actually valid.
And I thought,
well, that's fine.
If you want to be
that way, that's OK.
You can be a Disney princess.
I just wanted everybody to know
that there are alternatives
to that and so we
tackle a lot of issues
in this comedy, issues
of sexual identity,
of race and color,
body image, and thought
we would put a layer
of comedy over that
to make it entertaining
with Snow White at the lead
saying no to the
princess complex.
That's how Snow White became
the leader of this gang.
She was first.
ALAN: So you mentioned,
it was surprising,
you just said that
there are princesses
that were in the show and
now aren't, like there
were songs that were cut.
This gets later on in
what I'm going to ask you.
But what did you cut,
because you included so much?
And I feel like Lulu would
have fun doing all of them.
DENNIS GIACINO: True.
LULU PICART: Thank you.
I hope that you come to my New
York Fringe Festival one woman
show next year where I
do all the princesses.
[LAUGHTER]
Just kidding.
No, actually we didn't
really cut that much material
song-wise correct?
What we did is we started
out with a cast of 11 women.
And they reduced the cast
for production purposes.
And so therefore, Alison and
I play three characters each.
So that's kind of how it got
reduced but still managed
to cover the same
amount of ground.
Am I right?
DENNIS GIACINO: You're
absolutely right.
Before it ever
reached a stage, there
were songs that we had written.
We had other princesses in there
that weren't really princesses,
but they were part
of the Disney over.
So we had Jane Porter
who sang a song
with Belle called "Beast
of Burden" about the men
you fall in love with
and why, who knows.
And that's a great
song, but it's gone.
FIELY MATIAS: We
also had Peter Pan.
We had Tinkerbell.
We had Peter Pan as a
princess going well,
there's not going to be a
princes show without me.
[LAUGHTER]
DENNIS GIACINO: Right.
And yeah, so we had
Tinkerbell at one point.
LULU PICART: Esmerelda.
DENNIS GIACINO: Esmerelda was
in there at one point too.
So yeah.
We're fine tuned the show
and brought it to six actors
with 10 characters, I think now.
Yeah.
ALAN: Allison, all
your characters
are like drunk or crazy.
DENNIS GIACINO: It's
the crazy track.
ALAN: Yeah.
Jordan get that image ready.
We pulled the image of her as
Rapunzel off of the Facebook
page.
So Yeah you can throw that
up there when you want.
DENNIS GIACINO: The
German princess.
So this is here.
I want you guys
imagine this in light,
imagine this with costumes.
The costumes in this
show are incredible.
Yeah, I told you
it came off the--
ALISON BURNS:
Subliminal messaging.
ALAN: This came off
the Facebook page.
We just ripped it
off the internet.
ALISON BURNS: It scares you.
ALAN: Yes, so you've got
Belle who's literally
in a straitjacket who starts
out getting rolled almost
off the edge of the
stage in your chair.
And then who's next?
ALISON BURNS: Mermaid.
ALAN: Then you've got mermaid,
who's got a wonderful wig
and shaving cuts from not being
able to shave your new legs.
And then going to Rapunzel.
[LAUGHTER]
And then Rapunzel
which looks like look
like that, who is a dominatrix.
ALISON BURNS: Yes.
There she is.
ALAN: Yes.
ALISON BURNS: She's got a whip.
ALAN: She does and
hair that stretches
around the circumference
of the equator.
ALISON BURNS: Yeah.
ALAN: Which is your
favorite character to play?
ALISON BURNS: That's so hard.
ALAN: You've got to pick one.
ALISON BURNS: I feel like
it changes every night
because there are some nights
that, for instance, Rapunzel
really gets to talk to the
audience, which I love.
I never know what's
going to happen.
And sometimes you
have crazy people that
will literally stop the show.
ALAN: Oh, so she divides up
it's a singing contest where
she has--
ALISON BURNS: Woah,
spoiler alert.
[LAUGHTER]
ALAN: My arms are
just stuck like this.
[LAUGHTER]
I'm sorry.
Do you want?
I can stop.
ALISON BURNS: Nice recovery.
ALAN: So she divides
up the audience
and there is audience
participation.
ALISON BURNS: Yes.
And depending on how much
they've had to drink or--
ALAN: What is it's one red cent.
Not one red said.
Not one red cent.
ALISON BURNS: Yes.
ALAN: Very, very dominatrixy.
I assume that's
how they all talk.
ALISON BURNS: Yes.
I did a lot of
character research.
ALAN: Typecast,
typecast, typecast.
DENNIS GIACINO: In Tampa.
ALAN: In Tampa.
ALISON BURNS: In Tampa.
ALAN: All dominatrix in Tampa.
ALISON BURNS: Florida
where everything happens.
[LAUGHTER]
ALAN: So what--
MICHAEL RABY: We love
Tampa by the way.
[LAUGHTER]
For a visit.
ALAN: What is the craziest
thing or a story or two,
craziest things that
have happened to you?
ALISON BURNS: OK.
There was one night at
the old theater where
a gentleman in the
front row, I end
the song it's
supposed to be over
and he stands up and
went not one red cent,
like right next to me.
If you see, I have in
the picture a unibrow.
And I decided to take the
unibrow off and hand it to him,
like if you would
like to run the show,
by all means wear the unibrow.
And then the other
day, this gentlemen--
I don't know if you
were there for this,
but you'll love this--
so you know she's German.
And I walk over and I
happened to pick on a couple
people in the audience.
And I picked on this gentleman
and told him to do something
and he looked at me
and said, I'm Jewish.
ERIN LEIGH PECK:
I don't know why
you think I would love that.
ALISON BURNS: (WHISPERING)
Because you're a Jew.
ERIN LEIGH PECK: What
are you talking about?
ALISON BURNS: OK, so I lost it.
I am very good at staying
in that character.
But not that time.
He yelled that
and I was shaking.
And I told him out loud this
is the first time I've ever
been speechless.
It kind of stopped
the show for a while.
Everyone was laughing.
Snow White walked off stage.
I ended up throwing my
whip down and just turning
like it was over.
So things like that
happen all the time.
So all of you are going to
come and be like what can I
do to mess her up.
DENNIS GIACINO: Because
the show is a conversation
with the audience.
These princesses come to life
and they talk directly to you.
There's no fourth wall in the
show so anything can happen
and every show is
pretty much different.
And people come
back five, six times
because it changes
every night based
on what the audience gives us.
ALAN: Lulu you've got improv
experience says your credits.
[LAUGHTER]
ALISON BURNS: On your resume.
LULU PICART: OK.
ALAN: So I'll just.
[LAUGHTER]
ALISON BURNS: It's on the
screen now her resume.
ALAN: Buy tickets now.
We can switch back, it's fine.
It's scaring me, scaring me.
Yes, she down a airplane
bottle before she came on.
Yeah, so Lulu,
you've got improv.
I feel like are you
going out of your way
to try to make everyone
crack every night?
LULU PICART: Are you asking
me am I putting out 100%?
What exactly is the
question that you're asking?
ALAN: Do you give 110%?
LULU PICART: Well,
you know to be honest,
I've been in the show
for three years now.
And so in order to make
it fresh every day,
it's not that you make
a deliberate decision
to change up what you do.
But you have to make
a deliberate decision
to react to whatever
happens, especially
since what Dennis was saying.
We start the show off with a
direct address to the audience.
So when you see a normal play,
you're having a conversation
and you're the fly on the wall
watching the conversation.
In our show, you are
part of the conversation.
So if something happens
from the audience,
or if there's a reaction
we've never gotten before,
or if the laughter
stops the scene,
we have to realize that and
make that part of the scene.
That in its own sense is where
my improv training comes in,
because in improv training,
whatever happens happens.
That's the reality.
If it happens, it
happens in the room.
You accept it.
You say it out loud.
You say oh, yeah you
walked in through the door.
And then you walk
through the door.
There's no negating
anything that
happens which is a fantastic
way to A, go through life and B,
go through the show.
So that training I am absolutely
using it every single day.
ALAN: That's a little fun.
So Erin and Karen,
the two of you
are understudies for pretty
much everybody right?
ALISON BURNS: No, not
her, because she's black.
KAREN BURTHWRIGHT: Yeah so
that. (SINGING) I'm limited.
ALISON BURNS: So she only
covers the black girl.
KAREN BURTHWRIGHT: Oh!
ALISON BURNS: No,
she's our dance captain
if you couldn't tell.
ERIN LEIGH PECK:
She has to know.
ALISON BURNS: Karen
is our dance captain
and she teaches us how to
how to crunk and stuff.
ALAN: Right, right, OK.
KAREN BURTHWRIGHT: Nice dude.
DENNIS GIACINO:
She's from Tampa.
[LAUGHTER]
ALAN: Because she's from Tampa.
So what is it like, Erin
for you, you have to know.
Karen you know all the tracks.
KAREN BURTHWRIGHT: I know
everyone's track yeah.
ALAN: Everyone's tracks.
Erin, you know
everyone's vocal tracks.
So there's dance tracks.
There's vocal tracks.
Erin for you, which one do you
enjoy going on for the most?
[LAUGHTER]
ERIN LEIGH PECK: Well,
I mean did least--
ALAN: Song-wise.
ERIN LEIGH PECK: Right.
Well, the one that
doesn't scare me the most
is the one I've done the
most of, which is Snow White.
I happen to have done the
most shows as Snow White.
So I actually have a little
bit of an idea of what I'm
doing when I set foot on stage.
There has been a
time or two when
we were in the very early
stages of production
and you know these ladies
who do the show every night
were rehearsing during the day
and making changes to the show
and doing it at night.
And the understudies,
we were just watching.
We hadn't really
been rehearsed yet.
learned anything yet.
And I think I'd been
at work maybe two weeks
and had to go on
for Sleeping Beauty.
And literally, would like
to go out do a number,
go offstage, this crazy one
would meet me in the wings,
teach me the next number.
And then, they would
push me out there.
I tried to protest,
but they made me.
And then I would go out
there and do another number
and come back.
So those kind of experiences
make me a little trepidatious
about certain tracks.
But I think if I knew what
I was doing everywhere
in every second of
the show, Cinderella
would be my favorite because
Cinderella, the way that Dennis
has written her, just can
get away with anything,
because she just
doesn't know any better.
And she sees the
good in everything,
including every single
thing that she does herself.
So I think that
would be my favorite
because she's the freest.
DENNIS GIACINO: And to
back up, that's great.
Yes, it's sort of like the
Golden Girls or South Park.
They can say anything
because they're
cartoons or mature women, and
they just get away with it.
That's very much the Cinderella.
Karen has I think a
great story to add
onto this about
the one night she
went on as the frog princess.
KAREN BURTHWRIGHT:
Knocked it out.
DENNIS GIACINO:
The frog princess
got stuck in a train--
only in New York--
and couldn't actually
get to the show.
You have to show up I think,
what, half an hour beforehand,
or you're out that night.
KAREN BURTHWRIGHT:
No, I had nothing.
FIELY MATIAS: She
didn't have a put in,
nor did she have a costume read.
So tell us what happened.
KAREN BURTHWRIGHT:
So I don't know
if you guys remember,
I remember it well,
December 11, 2014, the day that
the trains were a hot tranny
mess and no one
could get anywhere,
that's the night in question.
Yeah, absolutely I did.
Quote me.
Ironically, we were
in rehearsal process
and Erin was going
on for Snow White
that night for the first time.
So as the dance captain
of this amazing cast
and this amazing
company, everything
was geared to getting her
prepped for that show,
because it was the first
time anyone had gone on
and we knew about it, which
is what normally happens.
So we had rehearsed.
We'd done her put in that
day, and of course, I
come to the theater for my girl,
supporting, proud den mother.
I can't wait,
focus, focus, focus.
No makeup, backstage,
doing the do, prepping her.
Half hour.
Do you need anything girl?
I got you.
You're going to be fantastic.
Put your wig on.
I'm here for you.
I'm not going to get in your
space, blah, blah, blah.
Trains.
No one can get anywhere
and even that day,
I was later than I wanted to be.
We has set a time
to get there, but it
was really hard to get to work.
So we get there and
people are coming late.
The audience is delayed.
It's that type of day.
So our Joy, who plays the frog
princess, is stuck in Queens.
She lives at the border
of Long Island and Queens.
So it takes her eight
hours to get to work.
And there's no express
option for her,
so she stuck on the train and
just letting the stage manager
know.
But this is way before half
hour, because I was there early
for her, focus on her.
Long story short, half hour
comes, she's not there.
Problem is, yes, she
has a delayed entrance
in the show, which is fabulous,
but our union rules and the way
we run this show just for
you guys in the audience,
normally, if none of
you are in the business,
if you're not there at
half hour call, that
presents a problem
because that's when you're
supposed to be there to prep.
And everything can
happen from there.
So at half hour, I was
like to our stage manager,
she's not here yet.
What you want me to do?
Do you want me to
get her stuff ready?
I was in denial, because I
teach, and those that can't do,
teach.
So in my head, I'm not going on.
She's going to get here.
What can I do to expedite
that process once it happens?
Actor's denial.
So half hour was 7:30.
She wasn't there.
7:45 comes around, he
has to make the call now.
So I'm sitting backstage, still
prepping Erin for her debut
as Snow White.
We're waiting, she
doesn't get there.
8:12, there's an announcement
that goes over this backstage
that I'm going on.
Me.
ALAN: Did the show
start at 8:00?
KAREN BURTHWRIGHT:
No, It was delayed
because audience members were
holding because no one can
get there on time.
Everyone was delayed.
So long story short,
I'm getting her ready.
There's places,
everyone's upstage.
Nothing, me in just
normal clothes.
My costume's in a bag with pins
in it because of my fitting.
All I did was try it on once
and there's pins everywhere
to fit it to make it whatever.
So I'm going on, lights go down.
Dennis is in the audience.
So he hears as the writer, the
creator of the show-- Fiely
wasn't actually there
that night-- Dennis
hears sitting out in the
audience waiting for the show
to start.
And at this
evening's performance
the role of the princess
who kissed the from
will be played by
Karen Burthwright.
DENNIS GIACINO: I was like--
KAREN BURTHWRIGHT:
This is brand new.
DENNIS GIACINO: --what?
[LAUGHTER]
KAREN BURTHWRIGHT:
So backstage--
DENNIS GIACINO: But she
doesn't have a costume.
FIELY MATIAS: I get
a text from Dennis.
DENNIS GIACINO:
Karen's in tonight.
FIELY MATIAS: Ugh.
DENNIS GIACINO: She
doesn't have a costume
and we haven't rehearsed her.
KAREN BURTHWRIGHT: So it was--
ALISON BURNS: You did it.
KAREN BURTHWRIGHT:
I did something
DENNIS GIACINO: She killed it
KAREN BURTHWRIGHT: --awesome.
ERIN LEIGH PECK: The
story was she was amazing.
DENNIS GIACINO: She
was great that night.
Yeah, didn't miss a beat.
KAREN BURTHWRIGHT:
Anything can happen.
This business is
full of surprises.
We all have firsts.
FIELY MATIAS: You more of a
dance captain, so you do--
KAREN BURTHWRIGHT:
Right, right, and that
helps in terms of whatever.
But it was funny.
Sorry guys, you're about to
hear me warm up backstage.
And it happened.
I'm sorry I couldn't watch
Erin in her performance.
I was watching
offstage when I could,
but I was what are
the words to my songs.
What's happening?
Where's my green eye shadow?
So it's just an amazing
show and it's so much fun
to play with these guys
and just act the fool
and make people laugh and bring
these lyrics and these stories
to life.
It's so much fun.
And it appeals to everyone.
The cross section of
our audience is unreal.
There's a 50-year-old
drag queen,
there's a straight couple,
there's 300 gay couples,
there's 300 tourists.
It's like everybody it's great.
ALAN: And that's just on stage.
KAREN BURTHWRIGHT:
And that's just
on stage. [EXAGGERATED LAUGHTER]
[LAUGHTER]
It's so much fun you guys.
It's so foolish.
ALAN: So we do have
microphones in the aisles.
If you guys have any
questions for the cast,
please pop up and ask.
DENNIS GIACINO: Don't be afraid.
ALAN: Don't be afraid.
They don't bite hard.
It's cool.
So the characters, all of
you have extensive resumes
and it's very impressive,
and everybody's
got roles that are very
traditional and very
like there's a fourth wall and
we will not break it and screw
the audience.
We are singing to each other.
Anybody, how are your roles now?
Do you like it now different
from the traditional sense
of theater or a little
bit column A a little bit
of column B?
Anybody?
LULU PICART: Oh, is that mine?
ALAN: Anyone, anyone.
LULU PICART: I've got it.
I like both.
As actors, we kind of
get into this business
because we like to
experience different things.
We like to live in
different lives.
different stories.
So this is wonderful
and normally we
don't get to talk
to the audience.
As an audience member, you don't
get to have that conversation.
So that's wonderful.
And since I have the
improv background,
that's home base for me.
But I also love
really boring plays
where you sit in a room and just
talk to somebody about life.
And then you move
to different bench,
and you talk about
life even more.
I love doing those
plays too, the ones
that my sister's
like great, can't
wait to see you in that play.
Oh, it was so interesting
when you touched your face
when you felt something.
So I also really love
that because as an actor
I crave those moments also.
Come see the show.
ALAN: I can tell.
[LAUGHTER]
Anybody else have
anything to add to that?
ERIN LEIGH PECK:
One of the reasons
I really love doing this
show is because I'm a mom.
And I've--
ALAN: Of two.
ERIN LEIGH PECK:
--had to-- of two--
and I've had to suffer through
the princess complex and all
of the marketing.
I remember my daughter,
who's 11 now actually,
was vehemently against
anything princess.
She took a very, very
firm stand about it.
And I was always
it was a problem,
because I need diapers.
But the only diapers,
literally, at the store
all had princesses on them.
I need a bowl a fork.
I couldn't buy
anything that didn't
have a princess or Dora on it.
And it's really hard
to avoid all of it.
So to be able to come
out on the other side
now-- and she's a
young lady-- and be
able to do a show that makes
fun of all those images,
it's really fun.
I get a little bit of
evil delight from it.
[LAUGHTER]
ALAN: Well, that
leads me to, I guess,
the true message
of the show is kind
of like the women are strong.
We don't need no stinking men.
The princess complex is
really like unnecessary
in today's day and age, right.
So with your two daughters,
two daughters right?
ERIN LEIGH PECK: No, I
have a son and a daughter.
He likes princesses.
[LAUGHTER]
He's completely into it.
He thinks it's awesome that
mommy plays a princess.
She's like really.
ALAN: So does your
daughter get the show?
Does she get the
message behind the show?
ERIN LEIGH PECK: Yeah,
totally, absolutely.
Look, our show is very PG-13.
It's not a kid's
show and I would
say that my uber mature New
York 11-year-old is probably
the border of about how
young a kid can be to see it.
But I was very excited to share
it with her because the message
is ultimately so positive.
It's such an empowering
message about girls
and getting away from this
image of the damsel in distress
and empowering yourself
to be what you want to be
and not having to fit into a
preordained mold physically
or emotionally.
And yeah, we tell a lot of
dirty jokes to get there,
but I think that the value of
live theater outweights that.
So I was really excited
to share that with her.
ALAN: That's really cool.
I'm going to shift gears
for a second real quick
in the final moments we've got.
Michael your kind of
your own character
off to the side of the stage.
So in the show itself,
there's the audience
and we're looking at the stage.
Then tucked off to the
corner where you can see them
and they can see you, is
Michael playing his keyboard
over there.
They interact with you
nonstop to the show
just like everybody else.
Is that kind of
thing new for you?
MICHAEL RABY: Oh no.
I have a cabaret background
where I'll play and sing too.
They're talking about
doing the show every night,
it's such a thrilling
aspect that the musicians do
because every night is
a little bit different,
and we roll with
the punches too.
And we're in there.
I play slide whistle as well.
[LAUGHTER]
Yes.
But yes, it's--
[SLIDE WHISTLE SOUND]
Yes.
Yes, and I had a lot
of training for that.
[LAUGHTER]
But no, it's a lot
of fun every night.
And all the girls, you're always
on that edge of our piano bench
waiting to see what
happens each night.
And there's a bass player
and drummer as well.
We're having a great time.
ALAN: Where are they?
They're not on stage.
MICHAEL RABY: They're
in back of the stage.
ALAN: Really?
MICHAEL RABY: So we have
a little video camera
so they see me and
I can talk to them.
ALISON BURNS: They're
in their pajamas.
ALAN: You know,
video conferencing,
work from home in
your underwear.
Yeah, question.
DENNIS GIACINO: Awesome, yes.
AUDIENCE: OK, so the
show sounds awesome.
ALISON BURNS: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hey, I can't
wait to see it myself
and I can't wait to take
my kids to see it someday.
But what are the plans
for the merch, the books,
and the action figures
and all that stuff?
[LAUGHTER]
When's it going to happen?
ALISON BURNS: Yes, t-shirts.
ALAN: I want an Alis--
LULU PICART: Did he
say action figures?
I love figures.
DENNIS GIACINO: Action
figures would be bobble heads.
ALAN: I want an Alison
Rapunzel action figure.
ALISON BURNS: Yes, one where
you pull the Rapunzel hair
and it just keeps
getting longer.
[LAUGHTER]
DENNIS GIACINO: Yeah
you know merchandise,
that's a funny subject
because we just started it.
So we of course have these
t-shirts, which this logo here
was created by Frank Fraver who
did the "Lion King" poster, you
know the yellow and black
one that you see everywhere.
And he's awesome.
It's kind of a fun
sort of loving poke
at Disney, almost
a personal roast
that they have a good time with.
So yeah, of course
there's merchandise.
It is a princess show
after all and so there are
mugs and t-shirts and magnets.
ALISON BURNS: Tiaras.
DENNIS GIACINO: What?
DENNIS GIACINO:
Tiaras if you want
to wear those
because again we're
not trying to say in
the show that you have
to be this type of princess.
We're saying you can be
any type of princess.
You can be a tiara wearing
princess, boy or girl.
There are alternatives
to that as well.
And the show really
is our happily ever
after, our answer to--
Disney's happily ever
after is you have
to look like this
and your waste has to
be smaller than you
neck size and the whole thing.
Our answer is no, living happily
ever after is loving yourself
for who you are.
Just be perfectly,
perfectly you.
That's our answer
in "DISENCHANTED!".
Another question, yes.
AUDIENCE: So my
two-year-old is obsessed
with "Frozen," which has a very
different take on the Disney
princess.
What do you think about that?
KAREN BURTHWRIGHT:
Never heard of it.
Never heard of the movie.
Don't know what
you're talking about.
DENNIS GIACINO: What?
LULU PICART: "Frozen," you said?
ALAN: Let it go, let it go.
It's fine.
DENNIS GIACINO: That's
a great question.
We actually have a
Frozen joke in the show.
But did you want to take
this one on "Frozen?"
OK, great.
LULU PICART: Well,
I actually think
that we're kind of on
the cusp of getting this
as a mainstream topic.
And I think the "Frozen" is a
really great example of that.
So you have a lot of
female-led comedy right now
that's out, female-led casts,
female-led dramas on TV.
You also have these
princesses that
are stepping outside
the normal role.
So the whole thing
about "Frozen,"
there's no main love
interest that saves the day.
The sisters save each other
through their own powers,
even though they're supernatural
powers but whenever.
So that is absolutely
something that we're seeing
us fit into that movement.
And so to be kind
of timed correctly
to be in with that
is really exciting.
I actually sang on the
"Frozen" Blu-ray of "Frozen."
So I'm in both worlds.
It's crazy.
But I think that that's one
of the things that resonated
with the audiences
so much in "Frozen"
is the girls were
like it's just me.
I can be a princess
and it's just me.
Everything is based
around what I do.
And that's kind of in the world
right now, which is beautiful.
DENNIS GIACINO: And Disney is
making strides in that too.
You've probably seen the
ads where Disney is trying
to redefine the word princess.
And they'll put out a
strong princess or two
like "Frozen" or "Brave."
And then they'll
turn out 10 more
that are just like Cinderella.
Afterwards, they go
there, we gave you one.
No, I think Disney is
also making that turn too.
When we started this
five or six years ago ,
we were sort of ahead of that
curve and that was great to be.
Now, the wave has come in and
it's a good wave for everybody
to ride.
So it's a great question.
Yeah.
LULU PICART: Even the, sorry
I'm totally going to elaborate.
The UN speech that Emma
Watson made a while back
where they started
the movement of you
don't have to be woman
to be a feminist.
All of that is in there.
So you have kind of the
highbrow conversation about it
and then you have the more
mainstream conversation
about it that we're kind of
using Disney as a reference
for because everyone has that
reference in their wheel house.
So it's nice to kind
of be that gateway
for those conversations.
DENNIS GIACINO: You're
absolutely right.
I'm going to elaborate on your
elaborate on my elaborate.
ERIN LEIGH PECK: You
guys, you know what?
We're going to go.
DENNIS GIACINO: OK.
No.
[LAUGHTER]
But no, we want to
be clear about it.
This is not a Disney
hating musical at all.
As a matter of fact,
I worked for Disney
at Walt Disney World.
You worked for Disney.
I mean, quite a few
of us up here have,
one of the producers.
And the idea is that we just
want to offer alternatives
as I've said before.
But it's not Disney hate.
I actually really like
the Disney product.
I just think it
could be widened.
And that's all we're doing.
So yeah.
ALAN: Yeah, last question here.
AUDIENCE: Actually, that
leads to my question.
Has the Disney corporation
given you any flak for this?
DENNIS GIACINO: Yeah.
No, that's always
a great question.
The first question I usually
get is how'd you come up it.
and the second one is do
you have a good lawyer.
[LAUGHTER]
Yeah, a lot of Disney higher
ups have come and seen the show.
One specifically is a guy
who has actually shut down
other shows, or a bar named
Grumpy's up in Michigan,
I think.
Yeah.
A Disney lawyer loved the show.
There's really nothing in the
show that warrants any-- it's
great question-- that
warrants any kind of copyright
infringement or legal action.
As a matter of fact, I
went to the same well
that Disney did which is
the public domain princesses
from the original fairy tales.
We make it very clear these are
my versions of the princesses
from the original story books,
which are all in public domain.
Disney has their versions.
That's why it's called
Disney's Snow White.
This is Dennis
Giacino's Snow White.
So there's that, and of
course then there's always
that First Amendment thing.
ALAN: You don't actually say
Disney in the show do you?
DENNIS GIACINO: A couple times.
ALAN: Do you?
I know you say
Walt all the time.
DENNIS GIACINO: We say Walt.
ALAN: Walt could be anybody.
Walt Thompson's Cinderella.
ERIN LEIGH PECK: I think
we're pretty clear on which
Belle's talking about.
ALAN: Oh does it.
Oh OK.
ALISON BURNS: And I say Mickey.
ALAN: That could mean Mickey
Thompson, Walt's brother.
DENNIS GIACINO: Right.
There are some references, but
again it's a good loving poke.
And at times it's
almost an homage
really to some of the Disney
over of princess films.
But no, nobody has ever
given us any troubles.
As a matter of
fact, they love it.
They get it, just like
everybody else does.
ALAN: Well that's wonderful.
We are out of time, if
there are no more questions.
Go to go/disenchanted-discount
to get your tickets please.
The show is wonderful.
Again, Westside Theater
Upstairs on West 43rd,
disenchantedmusical.com.
Are you guys on
the social medias?
ALISON BURNS: Yeah.
KAREN BURTHWRIGHT: We
love the social medias.
ALAN: What?
DENNIS GIACINO:
@disenchantedNYC is our Twitter.
Facebook is Facebook.com
backslash disenchantedmusical.
Go join and we don't bother you.
You can go and see
all the pictures
and there's backstage insider
info and stuff like that.
ALAN: Well, thank you all.
FIELY MATIAS: We love it here.
So anytime you want us
back, we'll come back.
[LAUGHTER]
KAREN BURTHWRIGHT: Yeah,
thanks for having us.
DENNIS GIACINO: You
have a hell of a cafe.
LULU PICART: Your
pizza is really good.
The pizza was--
ERIN LEIGH PECK: I had my entire
week's worth of vegetables
at the cafeteria.
So I don't have to have
any more this week.
ALAN: And froyo.
LULU PICART: I heard
you have nap pods?
ALAN: We do.
We do.
LULU PICART: It's like Sweden.
[LAUGHTER]
ERIN LEIGH PECK: Hashtag.
It's like Sweden.
ALAN: Right.
Well, everybody give
them a round of applause.
DENNIS GIACINO:
Thank you so much.
ALAN: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]